last year we talked about a woman who is
23 I think she might have been 22 at the
time and she is stuck in what some would
say is the body of an eight-year-old and
now she apparently has a boyfriend who
is 26 she's 23. hey no not hey yo not
but what is her option is she's supposed
to be alone for the rest of her life
can't be wrong if she dates a grown-up
man and then also
a person can I throw
up a man to date her because that means
he's into things that look eight years
old she's 23 in her mind she's supposed
to be in the mother that are old so
she's not doing anything wrong he's
doing something wrong if she's dating
other kids I mean she's also into
youngins but if we make it disgusting
for any grown man to date her yeah what
is she to do pig me what's that I don't
know what that means go to Congo data
Pig me the pygmies are these small
people that are in the jungle in um
Congo
looks like a child as well boom done